Speaker 1: A judge has thrown Carrie Lake's
lawsuit over the Arizona gubernatorial election
into the trash where it belongs. This
is great news and it is the right thing.
Judge Tosses Carrie Lake's Election Challenge
in Arizona Governor's Race. This happened on
Christmas Eve. A perfect day to usher in putting
this in the trash. A judge on Saturday dismissed
Carrie Lake's election challenge. Remember what
happened in Arizona? Very complicated. Okay. Pay
really close attention to what happened in
Arizona. More people voted for Katie Hobbs.
So she gets to be the governor. That's what
happened in Arizona. The judge dismissed it,
saying Lake failed to prove her case. Maricopa
County Judge Peter Thompson, who oversaw the two
day trial, ruled that Lake's legal team never
offered clear and convincing evidence showing
the election was rigged against her. Of course
he didn't. There is no such evidence because it
wasn't rigged. Lake can appeal the case before
Katie Hobbs is sworn in on January 2nd because
of the tight, tight, tight timetable. The case
may move swiftly to the Arizona Supreme Court.
Thompson noted real problems did affect the
election, but election workers tried their
best and performed their role with integrity.
Not perfectly, as no system on earth is perfect,
but more than sufficient to comply with
the law and conduct a valid election.
Here is her statement. After predicting endless
victories, she issued this statement. By the way,
if you're watching, she stands like Trump now.
She's doing that thing where she hinges forward
at the waist and it looks like it kind of defies
gravity. She's even standing like Trump. It's
bizarre here. She's calling this a win.
Speaker 4: I guess I'm just going to
make a quick statement. I am so
incredibly proud of amazing attorneys.
Speaker 1: I genuinely don't
know how people stand like that.
Speaker 4: After I put this amazing case
together, historic case, we proved without
a shadow of a doubt that there was malicious
intent that caused disruption so great it
changed the results of the election.
Speaker 1: They did not prove that.
They absolutely did not prove that.
Speaker 4: Incredibly proud of both.
Speaker 1: By the way, had she proven that,
the judge would have made a different decision.
Speaker 4: Olson, who led up his legal team. We
provided expert testimony. We provided experts.
The other side brought in activists to try to
save face. They admitted that they've
known about these ballot problems with
their ballot problems. Now they're trying to
say that's been going on for three elections.
Our elections are a mess in this country.
Speaker 1: All right. So anyway, I guess
she's saying it's a moral victory of some kind.
I don't really know. She also tweeted about this,
quote, My election case provided the world with
evidence. There was no evidence presented that
proves there was no proof. Our elections are run
outside of the law. That is not true. This judge
did not rule in our favor. That's accurate.
Okay. However, for the sake of restoring faith
and honesty in our elections, I will appeal this
ruling. Now, I just want to remind you the level
of confusion around this entire thing. Carrie Lake
said part of her evidence was that people weren't
allowed to vote because they arrived after the
polls closed. Understand, part of her evidence
is the polls are closed. People show up, they're
told we're closed. That's evidence. It was rigged.
Listen to this. This this is truly amazing.
Speaker 4: We have serious problems with
the way our elections are run. Let me just
read from some affidavits of people who were
taking part in Election Day voting.
Speaker 1: Which now you remember,
affidavits are not evidence. They can
be introduced as evidence and evaluated
like testimony, but doesn't even matter.
Speaker 4: Massive number of Republicans and
independents who showed up, this man says. At
7:00, a marshal announced that voting time was
over to the line outside of the building with
over a hundred voters still standing in line.
Speaker 1: Okay. Now those voters in line do get
to vote, but listen carefully to what she says.
Speaker 4: Four or five voters arrived immediately
thereafter and were very upset. One voter came to
the side door to speak to a supervisor.
Speaker 1: So I understand 4 to 5 voters
arrived after the polls closed. What happens
when the polls close is they say, okay, you,
sir or ma'am, are the last person in line. You
get to vote. Now no one else gets to get in line.
Every election is run this way. And part of her
evidence is an affidavit that four or five people
showed up after the poll closure announcement was
made and were upset they weren't allowed to vote.
The polls were closed. These are the rules in
every state. So the correct decision by the judge,
she's not going to be the governor. The person who
got more votes is going to get to be the governor.
We'll have all of these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.